oh there's a smudge on your face
oh that's just your face it is Friday
here on its grace and I'm toying with
this day being a variety of things
one idea hand was Good Friday another
idea head was fried diary where I take
you through a day of my life and that's
what we're doing today because today is
a very special day Hannah
mamrie and I are all going to a
screening room to watch camp Takota for
the first time the full movie and you
guys are coming with me
mamrie I guarantee you she's had like
four nervous diarrhea this morning
already we're taking an uber car over
there shoutout to over the car service
because we're so nervous about it we
might just do a shot or two three before
during and after let's go
good my name hello I'm filming you know
where's baby we're gonna go get it Oh
your first ah are you excited to be
first yeah first bacon gay
well name is coming memories coming yeah
are you excited me I've asked my
butthole yeah this is freaking out like
I told you guys car montage crying right
and as a pre anticipating the fields
that will happen during the movie
I brought tampons to wipe your eyes
where to plug your eyes with this is
gonna go on the Internet
you guys are hilarious I loved it that's
right I had for the best like pretty
here
hey you just listened let's talk about
how we're all gonna have diarrhea thanks
best override ever Vladimir right yes
make sure you ride with Lada mirror
thank you we're here a half hour early
by the way God the calm before the storm
storm memories about just bathroom now
just a mild red panic room to watch okay
let's choose our seats let's just do our
do we sit next to neighbor he's having a
gynecologist appointment
oh my god no okay we just finish
watching the movie holy macaroni
yeah I have electricity I love it
it's we are also um I would just like to
say how proud I am of this girl and this
girl right here this woman oh I feel
like I'm in a uterus okay yeah the lady
July nice not helping uh you just
watched it oh my god it's so I don't
want to be narcissistic about it but it
is I loved it and I'm embarrassed I were
not embarrassed it's bad no you okay the
thing is now you have to go preorder it
because we want you to see this so badly
Andrew my shoulders come up to my ears
when I'm excited
that's joy yeah go buy the movie it's
good if you buy one now you get the next
one for the same price
that's my infomercial the next night was
the next one I only buy one you get the
next one free but no oh we came in to
rock stream to talk about the movie
that's hat
they're having it weird haha
look at these offices are there near
barren they are like my vagina
completely bare
hey I was me awaited the end of the day
um uh-huh
god what a day it was the movie is
awesome I am so so proud of it and I had
a memory are so if you haven't already
please go to camp Takota calm and
pre-order the film is this yeah
human emotions make me not speak real
worth yeah anyway I hope you guys are
having a good Friday cetera et cetera so
on and so forth I don't know perfect yet
that's how you use a phone and then we
got that weird [ __ ] in that word stop
it
they're instagramming